okay four people joining this livestream
this is part of a long series of
meetings designing database integration
functionality fourth language and I
believe we're starting today with a kind
of a knotty problem about entities so
can somebody remind me what the problem
is
okay so where we left off last time
we're discussing weather weather when
you asked for the entry list of an
entity class for example whether the
single entities should remember that
they were coming from a specific entity
class and the the problem is that it is
obvious to everybody that there are some
things you can't just remove from the
entity forced arguments such as entity
extend because otherwise you cannot
perform the extension any more but some
others can peal the way and okay so
let's take an example here okay so so
you're saying if we make an entity class
here which is
have to say I'm not wild about the way
that this is displayed because when it
says countries here you know maybe what
this should say is Michael here by the
way yep maybe what this should say is
gray words class of countries
because that way it's not saying you
know it might suggest here that this is
kind of all countries which is obviously
not well I mean if you press the little
plus thing I'm pretty sure it shows you
the like what its selecting for right so
yes you just have to be careful that I
mean I guess it already has this problem
that class of countries doesn't sound
like all the countries right the class
of all countries but I guess we don't is
that also kind of suggests that it's
it's all countries you're right but I
think so class so entity food the like
bliss identities get a very similar
formatting that might be confusing I
think well okay but so we should unravel
that issue so what's an example of a
food case here Michael took their trip
cookies controlled equally but Jeremy
thought the distinction in the dots we
also stir one thing as bigger as good
enough I don't think it is I mean I find
it confusing every time they can quiz
people on who who is dot you know who is
really noticing the dots so explain to
me okay let's look at the different
cases here so in this case this is
recording the fact that you asked this
is a foods thing which it's about
chocolate chip cookies right but in this
case it's a country's thing I mean if
I'd said here now there are two very
different things because that country is
basically a list of country and for this
an implicit identity with it somehow
union or an aggregate of those whatever
you want to try sorry here it let's say
g8 countries oops
what does that do oh so that's an entity
class a named entity class Co if them
but then there are these generated
entity classes which are being
represented like this right and what is
this how can you compare this to those
other things what is that it's it's like
a mixture between course caning and
projection in the sense of vista
countries you can enumerate and
explicitly when the template give every
single one but the chocolate chip
cookies we have 620 of them it this
would be pointless because if you have
one you'd only know you have a chocolate
chip could be this is all your
information available as opposed to
subsetting which is the country's case
is that right technical difference is
that in the entity case you apply an
additional step first you select the
pair entities and then you aggregate
file in the entity class case you have
no application sorry I didn't understand
that you say in this case here if you if
you ask for a quality of this one you
get a list of they use whereas in this
one you get like you don't get six or
2000 orders are called calorie it's not
total calorie content I think
oh come on what what is the okay but if
I say sodium in chocolate chip cookies
that should show me what it is
I hope why is it spinning why did that
not work this I don't know right now
maybe look into it I'll say calories
this is I don't know what frozen I'm
running here let's take a look I don't
know
should I be running to see this oh well
you need alamode oh okay alright fine
fine but but but what this will do is it
will give a number if you give a number
exactly okay whereas you're saying if I
say percent one subpopulation it will
give a list it is it is I feel like
there's no intrinsic think it's it's a
human thing like to be you never refer
abstractly to one of the three possible
countries to one of the G AIDS you refer
to all of them or you know which one
they are they suspect you fruit and
materials you know it's a piece of steel
of the five thousand four hundred
standardized types of steel you don't
know which one it is so it would be not
useful to return this long list of
values right but but so there isn't a
sense an aggregator function which is
being applied which in this case is just
the function list but it could also be
the function total or it might be the
identity I don't know exactly what it
could be identity there right that
that's giving you that list whereas here
the result is some kind of mean isn't it
property yeah okay okay but but okay so
that's that's not the only difference
the other difference is that if you take
the entity class imply entity list to it
the reason and its list on the other
hand on an entity entities doesn't work
because you're not thinking anymore okay
so if I say entered a list a percent to
I think it does work for for niceness
because people wanted it but in some
sense it doesn't make sense but it
doesn't make I feel like
I mean it's a little engine
yes so it resolves to disgorge wherever
we think we know about this yeah
shouldn't this be just a property of the
fold like give me all the room steel and
instead of explore these are not
constituent these alternatives that
count as chocolate chip cookies it still
can be a properties of that but look
just the fact that you can expand this
thing but actually the issue is this
these are alternatives that is when you
say chocolate chip cookies you're
typically thinking of a particular
chocolate chip cookie and these are some
of the alternatives when you say g8
you're thinking of the aggregate of a
bunch of countries you're not thinking
of it's a country from you know from the
g8 one of them but I'm just not telling
you which actually you said the word
aggregate and in the context of every
it's probably the other way around in
that the cookies are a list of cookies
that get aggregated into a particular
medium or averaged cookie and the
countries don't get aggregated you could
also construct a cookie which is like
the sample well okay let's talk about
GDP per capita for the g8 in that case
you probably would want to aggregate the
countries not not if you're writing into
the class of the g8 that's not that's
not an aggregation and also the
aggregate of the GDP per capita of the
g8 is not trivial you can just do the
mean
however snacking holes does sound like
the kind of thing mum wants I mean the
g8 is just a filter of the countries
it's a subset of them yes okay listen
there's a couple of issues here so one
thing is we are representing an implicit
a a pop up entered
class I mean this is this is effectively
a pop-up entity class is that a fair
statement I don't think we have used
this phrase pop up but yes okay but the
thing that you guys are talking about
with entity extend and so on is another
form of pop up entity classes that a
true statement yes okay and and what we
are discussing here is in part let's see
is is is what is how to represent okay
so this is a pop up property okay so
this is an entity value
by the way is the alternative form here
to say countries in North America
brackets entity function
yes
okay does that work in a prototype build
yes to try it
so what you're saying is so so that
that's kind of nice actually I mean so
what you say let me just try this um so
you're saying
okay so let's take this thing here
why is that blue do I need to load
something I think meets entity framework
you
you
you
see this is another day
says
you
you
I'm sorry a story that's 14
okay so you say that's going to work
love whatever it's doing yes it's not so
hot to make it well this is really slow
but you're saying okay what was it doing
I mean it is retrieving one value at a
time okay all right so then this case
this will do the same thing
nope didn't but
posters because list has no submenus
so that evaluates to a list is that
right so in fact you were wrong when you
said that so this thing here you're
saying it
explicitly evaluates to that list so
it's in fact not an entity class anymore
yeah
so what's the way okay so that's so that
was a little bit of a confusion there
okay we don't have quite technology yet
to build dynamic entity classes based on
geo poverty's okay but in the case in
this case here we did build a dynamic
entity class so if I do to do this
then I can do of entity function
whatever right yes
oops
okay now let's say I wanted to take the
average of those
how would I do that would I just do mean
outside the whole thing
right now depends on the meaning of the
rod mean I understand I mean the other
case I would want to get separate lists
and then mess around with it
okay fine so let's come back to what
your question was so first my first
point is I think this is very unclear
what this is I think we should improve
that
um I mean we could maybe have a term
like computed class
for example let's imagine that this
wrist thing here said something like
um
but this visually said
little bit like it says geographic
region we could say something like
computed class but but what what will
you do what you have like a bunch of
nested joint aggregated things like at
some point there comes a point where you
don't even know what to call it anymore
like you know what it's like this yeah
like for example in in the end until
released by example if you think
countries aggregated by continent what
are they well where's there today I
could go to by example you must have it
somewhere in one of the old notebooks
but they're just target entity aggregate
by country continent right so I'm typing
country here country comma continent and
then new one rule that goes say let's
say you can say maximum no comma sorry
comma and then say something like
maximum population max population and
then you write entity function that's a
swing that's string no string max
population okay max P whatever it is
yeah arrow anti function x comma x max
no one acts max X population what the
does the max pee thing do
well like you need it because otherwise
you have no properties but what do I do
with this thing now well you can do
entity value on it and get out either
continental max P or both for using sub
values
okay so entity aggregate by which is
displaying as nothing here but it does
display as something or maybe not as the
case may be
hey what is this anyway so if you ask
for max P you're gonna get the
population of I'll try now
question here is is this yellow box
useful
I mean it's useful to see that the thing
didn't just sit there
you know dumb but this yellow box it
might actually be that that form is as
useful as the is more useful in the
yellow box I I think that we're gonna
hit the brick wall as soon as we have a
bunch of nested things question for
Michael and Tony do you think that I
mean why did we choose to make that
thing into a yellow box like this
because it is there there's no real
difference for most purposes between
entity class that we have defined and
one that you define but one that we've
defined that is g8 yeah okay so then we
say let's say create them okay
need some some compromise way to present
this where you actually can see all of
that text because I think it's not
particularly useful this form is as
confusing as is useful now this thing
here arguably is useful but that's
different thing because you've given
okay it would you head in your natural
language query yeah I know so let's
imagine that I said three largest
countries okay so really the right
interpretation will anybody who knows
well that's the right interpretation but
that oh boy so we're in it in the foods
case here oh I see
weird but it loses the chocolate-chip
cookie information there no I disagree
we discussed this one of the main reason
is it's it's also a question of identity
and equality like if you have a
misspelling
in chocolate chip cookies it's the same
chocolate Oreo cookies this means at
least off-label Asian they must be in
some kind of canonical form yeah okay so
this thing here oh well there is in fact
code for this and if I said input form
of percent 11 right
I will see that okay I think that one of
the questions is that like so far
entities were a thing that was pretty
much always accessed through control
evils and as we more move more towards a
situation where you can program with
entities I think that obfuscating the
input form might not be the best well I
kind of agree with you but but so but in
the case of this one here the input form
is quite impenetrable well it could be
made better now that we have entity
underneath by because if you think about
it this one is just saying take the
entities aggregated by foodtag and I've
an added food type and then the entity
ad could specify how which one of the
aggregates your table well okay listen
listen listen in if we look at this form
here right this local area take largest
three right that's clearly a formatted
thing and we could certainly that entity
property of food type could be formatted
that way making sense yes and similarly
this entity here so I mean there is a
form of this so just to be clear here
which is if I take this here and I do
command shift n work oh my god no it
doesn't what did that do how do I do
what I want to do here um well let's see
I could
in a pot and that inner part yeah I mean
so that's a perfectly civilized display
for this and arguably I mean this stack
display that we worked very hard on I
guess that that's a reasonable display
too I mean that's just a display of that
list yep
but when it gets more complicated using
that list will probably be a better idea
because it can have all kinds of other
functions in it
I was going to say the opposite if it
gets more complicated like for economic
stuff you really don't want to see all
of them what's a good example of that
seasonally adjusted this guy did exactly
this stuff seasonally adjusted
unemployment rate in 80 countries
well those are attributes right yeah
okay so what's your point over here so
that the issue is as we generate a more
complicated computer class how do we
display it because what we're doing here
right and right now this is just acting
dumb and just displaying as its input
right yeah did this actually look sorry
did that work if I did this work if I
say that max P does it work oh I know it
doesn't work is it supposed to work
I don't know it works with databases I
don't know if it works with I just fixed
some issues this using just a string try
typing entity property in full instead
of max P or all where word is the type
argument so I'm sorry what so to be
haste what should i type now
Tony what should I type now
I think you could try wrapping the first
document of Antony I cook a pie into an
entity class but yeah this will be fixed
in later notes so here in my country
around country started at the class and
then empty list as an argument empty
list
oh boy yeah now now try apply max P to
it now it's thinking
you
what the heck is that that's probably
Antarctica what is that yeah well just
just do instead of just max P doom open
list max P comma continent
yeah
what what's that is that is there a
country that is not any continent okay
how do I ask that question okay you can
do empty class country karma continent
goes to missile not available
rather annoying leader entity list
that's pretty wild is that right
hey does Christopher know if that's
right dude happen to know I mean I think
I'm not sure it's well-defined I mean
they're they're even different countries
have different definitions of different
continents so I yeah I mean I think it
probably could be thought of this right
but I'm not sure okay well there was
another thing that I wanted to point out
which is if you look at the oh let's
plot oh I see it's actually outlined in
those countries
I don't mind yeah go ahead so if you
look at the way that you like that that
implicit entity class is displaying and
the way the g8 was displaying and the
way that food was displaying I think
that we are lighting a lot of
information like the implicitly entity
class of countries and the g8 are
canvassing object food is a much
different object yes what are you
proposing so I mean the main issue is
for something like entity aggregate by
the question is how do we display this
is this the question and okay what is
what is an entity yeah okay so original
etiquette for in predicative we we've
decided that this so far for an
unchanging or a very slow changing world
now the question is we left off last
time saying that we should peel off all
filters out of the empties because you
eat and that's what we're doing right
now so yes if you ask for the end list
of empty class country g8 you forget
that it was coming from Jade but as soon
as you extend it adding some property
you cannot remove that class anymore
because it's inside and so you can get
in a situation where you have to pretty
similar construct and one is is
remembering the filter bubble isn't that
we Italians get out of the g8 and Spain
takes our place then what happens to the
anti list that you have left over in
your notebook should Italy still be
considered existing or not right now
this depends on the context
okay okay okay let me try to understand
this what is this I don't know if it's
this what happened here no that's that's
not that's not how things should work
yes what is this supposed to do now the
correct seat is on your left I don't
understand what that what that thing is
what is that okay we read the first one
the first one no the first one in the
second list so the first one is Canada
which has a lab that property that is
basically the name in lowercase yes okay
I see so that's wrapping the entity
class that's an extension to the entity
class that is being visit made visible
where exactly for every one of those
countries it's an extended entity class
that has that extension yes and so
basically the moment Italy stops being
in g8 the fourth entity in your list
will say missing a moment because the
filter will filter it out what filter
I'm sorry Oh dr. witches yeah countries
can get kicked in the g8 I mean we
really need to decide what entry list is
doing right I mean this is the West one
I mean what is the behavior that you
want enter this is some kind resolving
something and it's returning a list of
things so if you're going g8 it's
returning a list of eight countries now
the Western is do do we need to remember
this information I don't know probably
in my room
because if the p-value is also a
resolver and the value gives you a
result yes we need to decide what
entered list is resolving at whatever
this is not resolving
in my view you can't forget like you
can't forget some things about the
original query but since you can't
forget all of them then you will have
consistencies like the one you have hold
on look we all agree that entity value
like two plus two gives four and the
four no longer remembers that it came
from two plus two yeah that's fine okay
so the value is doing that it's a result
but empty list is like partial
evaluation okay let's talk about what
entity list means
what do we claim Anthony Lester's doing
first question
okay it's a bit vague and it's
incredibly short documentation here I
mean the Dean Caro is that you know if
you have like a symbolic and release
which basically Zen three glass right
then in the end the moment yeah a
country changes there when you when you
resolve probabilities again you will get
like it would be remember the original
context because it won't be lazy but at
least he is resolving right now to to a
list with the exact number of the
entities that were inside at the moment
you evaluated entry list yeah but it's
resolving the filter and and then I
think that at least the filter should be
stripped down because basically once
once I mean it's an aberration that is a
result in that no no it resolves less
than that Ricardo it only resolves it
would be the primary key which it's also
resolved the count right at this point
where basically you're saying you know
if you have something like you know an
entity list and greater and with
population greater than something right
since is resolving the count of this
thing yeah but the thing is that you you
end up being like we can peel off some
things but we can't peel off all of them
like some of these things I mean if the
outermost thing is an extension is an
aggregation is a join then you're
screwed you so the filter that you had
inside is still there so I thought I
understand that that when you're nest
and that's and that's something you
explain to me and I don't know why
you're doing about things about it now
well because we need to understand what
we are doing and and in this case the I
cities inconsistency you know yeah there
is a huge inconsistency and that's what
I pointed out on the
on the notebook that we said I don't
know I mean me we had our flower to
discuss the agenda now hold on hold on
hold on no I said it before when we
discussed that Antilles let's okay so
the question again is what does entity
let's do does it resolve to the problem
is that entities are no longer simple
things entities themselves have you know
in the past we thought of entities as
basically static end of the road you
know literals like numbers and things
but now entities can themselves be
computed in various ways
all right is that that's exactly the
point so the question is can entity list
so I mean put it in a particular way can
enter the list return entities that
still have to compute things ie you know
are symbolic but there's also as they
are no I think that they have to because
if you say something like entity extent
like the example that if you extend if
you strip off the entity extend then
there is no way you can access that
property out of the empty list anymore
because where do you raise it yeah
it belongs to a runtime type it doesn't
belong to the original one so the end is
you have to take to keep track of that
runtime type that was created
but I don't understand I mean Carl I
mean technically when you are resolved
in the remedy you do enter the list of a
crazy wedding like Greg ation and things
like that you put the filter in that
basically is either the gravity or
something more complex right
and so you are basically creating a new
filter out of an existing filter right
start correct - no I don't understand
what you just said you have an entity
verse with a filter
yes aggregation and everything yes and
then you want straw you call any list of
that yeah and now you take the query the
original query and on top of that you
build another filter
which is not a filter because by the way
there is the operations are generated
you know that this that the thing you
have on the second argument of entity is
indexing always a single entity as you
roll in that table so a single entity in
that list so there is a very big
difference between the first filter and
the second filter I'm losing this okay
look look the question is in entity list
what has always been the case in the
past is that Anton list returns the you
know explicit entities right yeah the
thing is that the entities are no less
explicit here it's just that they come
from around some type
what do you mean the entities are no
less explicit like if you look at the
entities that you have on the Left
selected those are very explicitly the
first one is Canada yeah but no but but
it is a okay the issue with it is that
it's had this weird property added to it
so it no longer is the entity Canada
it's Canada with this extension the
yes perfectly there's a choice here if
this is predicative or in predicative
one could still say it sick Canada it's
not obvious that it must be another
entity I agree yeah but like at least
from the point of view of the syntax of
the language philosophically you can do
that is still Canada but if you then
want to copy paste that another notebook
and ask for no I understand so this
entity extent thing is not going to make
sense anymore
why no no it doesn't because because as
you've said that entity extend might it
might conflict with in other words this
entity here may be an entity that you
simply simply isn't in the g8 anymore
exactly and that simply means that this
entity as a whole stops existing which
is correct right I think that's somehow
for me the form build it because it's
not existence is a problem outside of
the language but Michel there are two
different types of vibrations there are
operations that operate on the
properties light entity extend and all
things like filters sorting etc operate
on the entities themselves and so what
no disagreement okay so the claim is
that all the operations that exclusively
operate on the entities can be peeled
away obviously the ones that operate on
the properties cannot be killed away now
the question is really whether that will
end up making sense to our end users we
can go both ways but in the case we
don't peel anything there is that
equality on top of the other notebook
that phones even the case that we peel
something's away we have to explain
documentation that this had this hand
and this hand can be peeled away but
only if they are at the top level
otherwise if there are deeply nested
inside something else that we cannot
peel it away anymore and then we get
into situation like I was doing very
similar operation why did this one fail
and this one didn't and it's probably
not a big problem with built-in entities
because they don't change very often but
when we deal with external database if
things can change every millisecond so
it is important to answer this question
okay let's review again what the
question is
the question is do want me to formulate
or do you want to yeah go ahead okay so
the question is this given that in
principle we can say that a few
operations can be removed from the
definitions of the entity type while a
few others obviously cannot should we
like differentiate between the two
classes or should we always keep all
operations the main problem here is that
you are trying to keep a bunch of things
symbolic you know in the past everything
evaluated as soon as it could with
respect to entities there is a good
reason why we are trying to do this but
you're getting yourself tangled up as a
result of this and it's just like you
and you don't evaluate two plus two to
four then you keep it as two plus two
pretty soon you lose canonicalization
and the whole thing falls apart which is
you're seeing here you're losing
canonicalization because you've got a
bunch of history dependence for things
which are in fact the same they are not
the same
see that's what we're trying to show and
that sense it is because antibody is
always eagerly evaluating just values
and this stays half symbolic and so
that's the problem symbolic it's like
when you have entity if you ask for at
least every class country g8 you
evaluate something and then you can take
that note again five years later the
list of countries in g8 exchange what
about the possibility that we treat
entity list like entity value as an
eager evaluation thing which can leave
no symbolic structures left and so what
does how can you really symbolic
structure no no this extension for
example this extended stuff would just
say that's nice
okay now the extension is trivial to
leave it that I think it will be an
error
what do you the emulation of the
countenance
what do you return there what do you
mean the aggregation turn back to the
other example
there where you did and she agreed by if
you want list of that
what are these single entities of that
well so let's take a look and today what
is it right now so let's say I'm 15
you
what the hell is that
what is that that's for every country
for every continent the first one is
gonna be just take the first yeah
whatever that weighs that that's every
country in that first continent that's
results just say Europe or whatever in
the first in the second argument well
what happened here this particular
features not implemented yet that's why
we need this input to finalize what we
actually want what should this do in my
opinion we need to preserve the
particular identity and discipline and
the identity is if we say entity value
of a class comma property then we get
certain things out if we did the same
but applied entity list to this entity
class then we need to get the same
result if you claim that then my example
on the left what I'm saying enter the
last word right energy value write this
energy value of query drama properties
is even equals 20 Diwali and list of
creamy common properties
yes and for this identity to hold in
certain cases like in aggregates and
joints we need to have more complex type
information in the first argument of
entity in all cases also entity class
because because of the evaluation
semantics of the language and the list
will evaluate separately and if that
means second something changed this
doesn't hold anymore for application
careless behavior is now grown like you
know let's say that you have like an
application that got people in inner
delegates right and you search by email
you search with my email it said this
database you get you get at one guy and
then if this guy changes Daniel this guy
opps existing that would be confusing to
people because now you got this entity I
don't know Ricardo something and just
because I change the email I stopped
myself or something you know it's it's
really it's really something that I
think is if you if you change yes I mean
what determines the identity of an
entity i i i don't think that equality
between all trees is well-defined like
what i'm saying is that for real for
real data you know if you if you have a
query and you do a complex query and the
data changes a lot basically this entity
will become meaningless in a few in a
few seconds you know because the the
data underlined if it's changing a lot
then then basically you know this query
is not meaningful for anymore i think
like this thing is it's useful if is
basically you know you do enter the list
of something and you get out an entity
that is identified with a primary key
now that that is useful because it never
change you know that's not that's not
true you can't do that there's no way
you can do that and the example on the
left exam exactly
you can do that I mean the moment it's
it's a different quality the moment you
resolve g8 you get out eight guys and
they always stays like that right
symbolic they don't stay like that they
are not resolved with their values they
not resolve to their values because
they're so handles to two bureaus
they're not actual values well you say
entity go ahead okay I was saying that
when you resolve a little list you get a
list of entities there are still
symbolic handles they're still AZ the
only thing you resolve about them is a
primary key that's it everything else
but if you resolve the primary key is
that you are resolving something and you
are resolved with the count you're
resolved in the primaries and now the
fact that you'll remember is some
information about the wedding it means
that this this can stop existing this is
not useful at all I think which only
tells you that entity Lister's is about
is not a very well thought out
abstraction absolutely but if we have
that the only thing that is that is
meaningful to me that these things
should do is that basically your resolve
like to a list or entries I got
primarily and you just document the fact
that basically yeah you have resolved
the filter yeah if you if you think
something like there is nothing special
about the the canonical name like you
can construct an entity aggregate by as
we should have shown with with the
content and so you can do it with
international organizations and then at
that point the primary key of the table
becomes something that is dependent on
the data but not changing so in some
cases you have you have things that
don't change in some cases you have
things that change I think it just gets
very confusing why what is that mean for
why do we want entity list
I don't but but I'm just asking I mean
what we would do is that basically you
can also say that any list of an
aggregation or something it's it cannot
be done you know I mean it doesn't we it
doesn't it only works for three are
cases which is basically you know a
simple filter right now and I think this
is a sensible thing to do I mean at
least to me it would be confusing if you
know the I gather eight entities and and
one of them will will will stop existing
because there was the filter inside but
in some cases that will happen
regardless those cases we just we just
don't don't make possible in the list we
just either fail or something well the
other possibility is that entity list
resolves and strips everything it just
is a convenience from how can it
straight you cannot really do that
Steven because if it is an aggregation
or a join or something then then this
wouldn't work so may summarize three
different cases by B my plot there's
three different reasons why we might
want to preserve structure in the first
argument of entity so one reason is we
are creating a completely new table in
during an aggregation or doing a joint
there's no way these new entities are
related to the original tables they came
from so there's no way around it
the second case is we're introducing
some new properties we need to keep them
to because otherwise the entities that
we get don't have these properties
anymore and then the third reason is we
need provenance where the entities came
from to decide whether they still exist
or not I don't understand that last one
that means in the notebook on the left
you see entity list of entity class
country g8 the question is will be
preserved the entity class in the first
argument of entity or not if yes then we
would know that the entity I think
that's not a correct case I think by the
time you're doing Anthony list at the
moment when you do it you decide whether
the entity exists or not
except you cannot always do it and the
second example shows that like they're
very very very similar and yet they have
completely different results like
actually if you if you ask only for if
you don't ask for the extension you ask
for the population in both cases they
should effectively be performing the
same operation because the extension is
like basically simplified out and yet
they will return different results you
know oh boy
ok we are again running out of time what
are we going to do here
I think we need a continuation
unfortunately yes
but I think you know the first thing
we're realizing here is that you know if
we just said entity list only works in
the trivial cases
would that solve our current problem
not sure that it would do that entirely
because the real problem is with single
entities more than with any list okay
also what the real problem I think is
with single entities because they think
appear in other places as well such as
you know entity property Association or
other forms of entity value in a way in
which to return because even if we have
things like entity property Association
even in that case we still have the same
issue about single it is what why what
this year which is that we are whether
we want to keep the entire runtime type
or not and I think that both we me and
recorder with on Carlo we think that yes
okay wait wait wait wait wait so entity
value we all agree that that's not the
case
enter the value you know immediately
evaluates to whatever the value is the
value of entities and that's equivalent
20 list you can still do energy entity
association yes that's what I was saying
and that sent list so I mean we can't
just sweep the thing under the rug what
entity value yeah then you do work
whatever you want and stick last g8
whatever and then you say comma and the
Association you need another property
before you do that otherwise you get
huge results say population there yeah
and so if you think
keys of this then you have single
entities again and yeah I understand so
the issue is but we could insist somehow
that when it passes through entity value
that it resolves resolves Walt
well entered a Association could be
defined to never allow a computed entity
here but but what if it's what if the
entities are the aggregates with
continents then you how do you still
need that to identify them yeah I
understand and the problem is that has a
runtime matter one of those entities
might decide it doesn't exist anymore
and that and that can happen even with
Bayes entities like if you have a
database with the orders on or for
exactly now our own bugs database when a
body is closed it gets moved to another
table so the bugs stop existing as it
was yeah
such as the flag this is a nasty problem
or insincere in some sense this problem
reflects that the single entity is not
the best abstraction because we always
want some properties from entities the
concept that an entity is ultimately a
literal you know that it actually
resolves to something yes in some sense
you could say nothing ever resolves same
thing that you could do you know if
you're doing math you could say nothing
ever resolves that is if you want to
track through you know oh my gosh let's
not resolve it because X might be 0 and
X over X might not be equal to 1 well
actually you can resolve entity classes
and that's perfectly fine they are very
well defined concept sure no only these
literal entity causes not an implicit
entity class and app listed entity class
might say you know countries with more
than a billion you know with population
more than a billion yeah but the
resolution of that will change over time
oh yeah that's for sure well but that's
that's also true of the main ones yeah
like as soon as new countries join the
European Union the name that's not a
problem for Nancy cross Handford for
membership yeah operate in a sense so I
mean my theory is really that you know
you have some code that is running like
over over some data that really changes
a lot and and if you and if you're using
get released in my period after a few
milliseconds when you do the other
operation that thing stuff stopped
existing it can be that of course like
the Antony was deleted in anyway so of
course that it there is always the
chance they stopped exists but if you
have like a clear reference to the entry
that is done by the primary key there at
least a couple of milliseconds later
your
still in good shape probably to use and
release when you have this kind of data
but but still people can do it like this
kind of mistake or you know we I would
like not not you know III think this
design can really be problematic when
you have when you're dealing with
real-time data or things like that and
alright we have to pick this up another
time
um frustrating let's try to pick it up
within a few days so we have not
forgotten the issues
okay yep yep okay